I think people misunderstand the entire nature of gratitude
with all of the posts I make
which a lot of the times have to do with setting boundaries with family members
or creating space for self care in motherhood
the number one critique I get is that I sound ungrateful
and I think this really comes down to the nature of how we view women
girls and mothers
we truly only value women
who are prepared to be selfless within their roles in life
the second you start advocating for your needs or setting boundaries
you are called ungrateful or selfish or entitled
that's the other one I get
and the reality is maybe this is my neurodivergent brain
but like multiple things can be true at once
I am in love with being a mom
I gave up my career to be a stay at home mom
I homeschool my kids
but that doesn't mean that I
don't want Mother's Day to be a day where I feel special
and pampered and important and celebrated
I can love and appreciate and respect my own mother
while still setting boundaries with how she treats me
I can appreciate the relationship that my in laws
or extended family have in my children's life
and still expect them to treat me with respect
and adhere to my boundaries for their care and safety
these things are never mutually exclusive
but the amount that it triggers people
that a woman could possibly set boundaries for herself
for the people in her life and for her own mental health
shows just how much we expect women to stay silent
to be agreeable
to be subservient
I have dedicated my entire life to the service of my family
both before I had kids and got married as a daughter
and now as a wife and mother
and I only recently Learned how to advocate for myself
and it is very
very telling how that rubs people the wrong way
because I never said I was not grateful for everything
and all the people in my life
we are just so used to women not asking for what they need
we would rather a woman burn out than be disagreeable